[Applause]
thank you so much for coming you
beautiful highline creatures
you gods and goddesses thank you so much
for participating with us today we'd
like to welcome you to the show and
today we're airing it out on new york
city's high line
and we're not doing it alone
no no no because today we've got the
most
special guest you know who's gonna help
me get into some headlines right away
well it's time for drew's news your
daily brain scrub with the good news
squeegee
and with me at the desk is a very
special co-pilot today she is an
award-winning actress and a dear friend
and please welcome back to the show
dakota johnson
sorry
you know jacob and i have known each
other for a long time yeah like
uh i mean god how old were you when we
first met when i would see you with your
mom at the hair salon i was like 14. i
would see you at our hair salon with
your mom
and it's funny too because i was like
young and not a mom yet and yet i always
felt very sisterly very like i would
play with your hair
i i crossed a lot of lines
um immediately with you i felt very
magnetically drawn to you and i was
always pawing at you yeah you would pick
through my hair and be like i want this
color
and this color it's true you always have
had the best hair colors thank you i was
a blonde person then um well for anyone
who hasn't been here the high line is an
incredible public park that stretches
for
20 city blocks on a historic elevated
train track
i remember back in the day when i used
to go to a bar down the street called
hogs and heifers anyone remember
hold on did you ever go to hogs and
heifers i didn't well it was i can't say
that i did it was famous because girls
would get up on the bar and dance and
then remove their bra in an appropriate
way kind of like
flash dance jennifer beale's style
you know like into that
art of removing your brassiere with
clothing on and then they would leave
the bra on the giant
heifer that was mounted on the wall so
there were thousands of bras
and it was the coolest it's not there
it's just a plaque now that's sad like
remember the good old days they're over
all right well since we are here at the
historic high line
um
i say we get into some headlines
yeah headlines highline headlines let's
jump into the news all right first up
we've got to talk about neighbors we've
all got them
uh but are you best buds with them are
you strangers do you avoid them what's
your deal with your neighbors because
town and country reports that before the
pandemic data showed that 30
of people were friends with their
neighbors while at the other extreme 30
percent
said they were total strangers but a
more recent study found that during the
pandemic one out of three people said
they got a lot closer with their
neighbors
dakota
what is your neighbors like who are they
and what's your relationship with them
one neighbor i don't talk to and then
the other neighbor is jimmy kimmel i
love him i love him too and i don't know
his wife molly is amazing okay so those
are great neighbors are amazing
neighbors except they have a lot of
parties and they don't invite me
is this for real because you know people
have gotten in trouble for claiming not
being invited to your parties
that was amazing by the way
like amazing
and the neighborhood's not so nice
no i actually they're probably fine they
just really like to cut my hedges
without
asking
but they're probably nice people have
you ever said i like a full bush
don't trim that don't turn the hedges
um
no
i'm not really a confrontational person
okay okay they'll grow again all right
um next we're going to move on to some
breaking news about your bathroom so a
study finds that
science literally decoded this and
discovered that the number one dirty
area in your bathroom
is
your towel rack which
i don't have a towel rack do you have a
hook
um no do you air dry before
straight onto the floor do you have a
hamper yes i do which is such an ugly
word
[Laughter]
sometimes i get caught i i cause i'm
hamper so much quicker than laundry
baskets so i'll say to the kids hey
don't forget to put that in the hamper
and i'm like god i hate that word
yeah um
so no hook no basket just on the floor
well i guess your floor might be the new
bathroom pole dakota
[Music]
it's your story listen drew there's no
shame in a dirty towel rod nor a [ __ ]
stamp apparently
the tattoo trend from the early 2000s is
back the blog scary mommy says gen z is
all about the lower back tattoo
first order of business let's change the
name
we could call them
back jazz or
tail art or spine design or butt crown
the butt crown
i'm warming up to it i like butt crown
[Applause]
i feel like it was unfair to women to
just say you've got a [ __ ] stamp now i
have a lower back tattoo i don't want to
be called a [ __ ] you do
i do what is it it's um it's little tiny
angels i got them when i was like 13.
oh that's really cute it's not a [ __ ]
stamp no
it's a butt crown it's a butt crown news
this week drew barrymore not a [ __ ]
exactly thank you very much
all right well next we've got another
addition to our vocabulary it's deleted
dating term in style reports that if you
are dating someone
new
who you really like but then you
backslide and maybe you
text an x or you go on a random date
with someone else okay this phenomenon
is now being called
temperature checking
temperature checking
i think i think be careful with
temperature checking don't blow it over
a temperature check that that would be
my advice
i feel like if you need to take the
temperature you probably
aren't feeling the heat you know what i
mean
thank you
i much prefer your review of this
subject all right you take this story
and finally once you're in a
relationship how important is it to
share a bed a piece on gawker recently
suggested the dream relationship
consists of not one but two bedrooms
a lot of people are fans of this couples
who sleep in separate rooms say they
love the private space and they get way
better sleep
what are your thoughts on this i like
one bed
i don't like i don't like separate beds
but like whatever blows your bangs up
[Laughter]
all right well before we go we have a
brand new movie coming out in december
that's truly built by a powerhouse super
team of humans and it's called
the lost daughter
and it is starring you and your majesty
olivia coleman written and directed by
the incredible maggie gyllenhaal
it was all the rage um at the venice
film festival can you illuminate us
on why everyone is just floating on air
over this beautiful project of yours
what maggie did with this film is
something very different and very honest
and it's
about women and how
complicated and troubling it can be to
be a woman in the world and
to be a mother
mother-daughter relationships and
it's so beautiful and olivia is like
well i'm so happy for you and i love
everything that you do and you have
tea time your amazing production company
that also is a beautiful curated list of
all things i highly recommend deep
diving into this gorgeous world
that you've created
that has a tremendous femininity
and a tremendous european flair and yet
it's so confident and yet so breezy
there's
it's so artistic without ever being
alienating it's such a welcoming
destination
yes
mic drop
[Music]